you have probably heard other people
refer to product managers as the ceo of
the product
i disagree because product managers
simply don't have any direct authority
over most of the things needed to make
their products successful
from user and data research through
design and development to marketing
sales and support
so what should you consider if you are
thinking of pursuing a product manager
role
aspiring product managers should
consider three primary factors when
evaluating a role
core competencies emotional intelligence
and company fit
the best product managers have mastered
the core competencies have a high eq and
work for the right company for them
beyond shipping new features on a
regular cadence and keeping the peace
between engineering and the design team
the best product managers create
products with strong user adoption that
have exponential revenue growth and
perhaps even disrupt an industry
there are core competencies that every
product manager must have
most of these are developed with
experience good role models and
mentoring
some examples of these competencies
include conducting customer interviews
and user testing feature prioritization
and roadmap planning resource allocation
translating business to technical
requirements as well as defining and
tracking success metrics
a good product manager may know the best
practices of the customer interviews but
the best product managers have the
ability to empathize with customers in
that interview are tuned into their body
language and emotions and can astutely
suss out the pain points that the
product or feature will address
a product manager with a high eq has
strong relationships within their
organization and a keen sense of how to
navigate both internal and external
hurdles to ship a great product
one of the most important
characteristics of a great pm is their
relationship management skills
great pms shine at successful
negotiation resolving conflicts and
working with others toward a shared goal
which is especially challenging when a
pm is tasked with balancing the needs of
customers resource constrained
engineering teams and the company's
revenue goals
authentic and trusting relationships
within an organization can lead to more
support when additional funding is
needed for a product or when an engineer
must be swayed to include a quick bug
fix in the next sprint
outside an organization these skills
could encourage existing customers to
beta test a new feature for early
feedback or to convince a target
customer to try the mvp of a product
still in stealth mode
these relationship skills can also be
what makes the difference between having
angry customers because of a bug
introduced into the product and those
who say no worries we know you'll fix
this
being a product manager can be
incredibly stressful
the ceo wants one thing the engineering
team another and customers have their
own opinions about feature priorities
product managers must understand
customers emotions and concerns about
their product as much as they understand
the concerns of the sales team on how to
sell that product or the support team on
how to support it or the engineering
team on how to build it
managing tight deadlines revenue targets
market demands prioritization conflicts
and resource constraints all at once is
not for the faint of heart
if a pm cannot maintain their emotions
and keep it cool under pressure they can
quickly lose the confidence of all their
constituents
the best pm know how to push hard on the
right priorities with urgency but
without conveying a sense of panic or
stress
these product managers also know when to
take a breath and step away to regroup
if the best product managers have
well-developed core competencies and a
high eq does that mean they are destined
for success no matter where they work
not necessarily
in fact taking these skills and
personality traits and applying them to
the right company is what will
ultimately guarantee success
companies differ in what they want from
a product manager
some companies over emphasize technical
skills
for example google requires all product
managers to pass a technical skills test
if the company is building a customer
relationship management software there
may be more requirements around
experience with go to market and
customer life cycles that around how the
product is built
by contrast if it's a data science
product with machine learning algorithms
and api the role may require a lot more
technical depth to not only understand
how to build the product but also how to
talk credibly with the customers who
will use it
every company has a different philosophy
about the product development process
and where product managers fit into that
process
in smaller companies product managers
usually drive engineering the gather
requirements write the product
requirements documents and hand it off
to engineering to spec out the technical
solutions
the general expectation is that product
managers know best about what customers
need and engineering is there to serve
on the other hand in more technically
oriented companies engineering drives
product
the cloud ai big data blockchain and
networking companies tend to be
engineering driven where engineers are
advancing the science in their domain
and product managers validate solutions
or create front end access points such
as ui and api to tap into this new
technology
there can be a collaborative
relationship and feedback loop between
customers pms and engineering but
typically product managers are serving
engineering in these companies
in some earlier stage companies it's
important to know how involved the
founder ceo is in the product process
if they are deeply involved the pm role
may play more of a support role to flesh
out their ideas or validate concepts
with customers versus conceiving and
driving ideas of their own
this can be great fun for some product
managers who enjoy partnering with
founders and collaborating on the
product evolution
but for other product managers it can be
very frustrating if they prefer to take
more ownership of the product direction
it can also be challenging if the more
technical founders prefer working
directly with engineers
this can leave product managers out of
the loop causing not just personal
frustrations but delays
when considering a pm role that may work
closely with the founding leadership
team be sure to find out their
expectations of the pm function and
decide whether this is the right fit
with your interests
there are of course many other factors
to consider for any product manager role
such as the type of product you are
building the people with the mule work
the overall company culture and of
course the compensation and benefits
there are also lots of articles on
hiring product managers to get
perspective on what the hiring managers
are looking for
however if you are striving to be a
great product manager consider all of
the above before signing on to your next
gig
developing core competencies will be an
ongoing activity throughout your career
and leveraging eq will ensure a more
positive experience
but where you work how they work and who
you work within for will ultimately
determine your long-term success
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day